hello everyone it's peter brown with a
gamespot news update if you're waiting
for project cars to come to your wii u
wait no more cuz unfortunately the game
has been canceled after numerous delays
slightly mad studios confirm that
project cars will not be drifting its
way onto the wii u a representative for
the uk's studio creative director Andy
Tudor has apologized to Wii U owners who
had high hopes at the racing sim would
ship on Nintendo's home console despite
much perseverance on the Wii U version
of project cars we will no longer be
actively pursuing development on it as
the quality does not meet our own high
standards nor our intended vision for
the title on this platform shooter went
on to say we eagerly look forward to any
announcement of further hardware from
Nintendo right now project cars is
simply too much for Wii U despite our
very best efforts project cars came out
a few months ago on pc playstation 4 and
xbox one and we gave it an 8 out of 10
saying project cars doesn't deliver a
fantasy of accumulation in progress what
it does deliver is a simulation of
racing as tense as it is deep well too
bad for Wii U owners but at least you
still have Mario Kart 8 for all your
gaming news and more stay tuned and
gamespot com